turns out we're all using a can opener
wrong how should we be
that's that's what i hear so so
basically
i mean i've been using it kind of like
this
like but i think most people do like
they put the can opener on top but
apparently you're supposed to put it on
the side
all right we're going to watch a video
that corroborates your story
this is how i used to do it so you're
going to hold it like this
so the blade is going to be on the
outside and then it's going to click
and you're just going to twist it all
the way around
and watch how easily it just comes off
and it comes off attached to the can
opener like this
oh that does at first i was like yeah
potato potato do it whatever way you
want but
the whole snapping of the lid coming off
right
like it just okay
yeah mine worked look that's actually a
pretty that's actually pretty good
i have to say i have not and i don't i
didn't do it like this
um okay my can opener is not working
hold on a second
all right wait what all right
[Music]
just throw it against the wall
okay i can tell you what i'm not going
to be doing i'm going back to my
old-fashioned way
um all right next do we have a specific
way
to use a strainer this i'm intrigued by
because i'm a big strainer i'm always
boiling pastas and stuff
so apparently this is the easiest way
now
to do this i haven't seen this i'm
watching it for the first time go roll
the tape
show me the life hack that you randomly
saw one day
that is now an unconscious standard
practice in your life i'll go first
oh yeah i've never done it that way
bobby
i'm not into it i do it like everybody
else does it
i would just put it in the sink and i
would just pour the water
into the strainer and the reason why i
like that is because i can see where the
hot water is going don't forget a lot of
times this water is
really piping hot once you cover it
and you start spilling out the water
there is a possibility
i think that the hot water can go places
that you don't want it to go
and i can't really see the hot water
coming out from under the strainer
just in case i just don't like it i want
to see where my hot water is going at
all
now my straining upside down went a heck
of a lot better
than my can opening situation so i'm not
hating the strainer half as much as i
hate that darn can opener situation
so all right well i'm i'm sort of the
opposite i'm kind of into the can opener
but i'm not into the strainer so like we
each are 50 50 on that but
opposite opposites attract to each's own
we both
picked up something new today on
tick-tock and i have to say
i am loving tick tock it's like they're
just reinventing
hacks and tips about life everyone's
expressing themselves
so i enjoy tick tock and i'm glad yeah i
do too
it's very fun it's educational it's
teaching us fun stuff
okay we must do this again bobby i can't
thank you enough and
nacho if i may whisper in your ear thank
you for taking care of all these rescue
kitties
and giving them so much food and
providing
for them and being such a philanthropic
kitty okay now keep an eye on our
website for nachos interview for our
digital series
pause for pause because that's coming
soon and that's going to be amazing i
mean look at
come on nacho you are
so handsome i'm just gonna say
i was gonna say you get on that kitty
tinder
and you swipe right yeah
i think it's a match indeed thank you
bobby so
much we'll be right back
[Music]
you